In Islam, a woman can demand mah
depending upon the status of the man
she's marrying. She can demand anything
whether 1 million rupees, 2 million
rupees, 5 million rupees. That's a
different question. If the man can
afford and he wants, he will pay. If he
can't afford, then either she comes down
or she finds another boy. But she can
demand. She has the right to demand what
she feels she wants.
And no one can stop her.
If unfortunately if divorce takes place,
she gets the maintenance till the for
the period. And if she's pregnant, she
gets maintaining she till the time she
gives birth to the child. And if she has
children, she gets maintenance of the
children till they become adult.
Financially, she's secure. And if she
marries again after divorce, she gets
new marriage.
So financially secured the man is to
give the woman takes
and if the husband dies
even during the period she gets
maintenance 4 months 10 days and if she
die and if the husband dies a father
dies a woman inherits in most of the
religion the woman do not inherit from
the parent or the husband in Islam
a woman inherits
from the father, from the husband, from
the children, from many relatives.
So in Islam,
a woman is financially secured.
This is true and practical gender
equality.
Allah doesn't say that.
No, no, both work equally.
You have to understand equality doesn't
mean identicality.
Equality doesn't mean identicality
because the men and women they are made
biologically different, physiologically
different, physically different. So
depending upon their biological nature,
their physiological nature, their
physical makeup, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has assigned different roles
for different genders.
That means that is true equality.
Therefore, the topic of my talk is true
and practical equality and Islamic
solution.